[Music]
this is exciting president obama trying
uh to get out the youth vote in new and
interesting ways
and uh today and this might be a first
today president obama answered young
people's questions on youtube
he went on youtube the president yeah as
a result obama's latest poll numbers are
55 lol and 45
totally gay
that's a response
people said totally gay is the answer to
about 50
yeah it's 50 of the comments on the
internet about anything yeah yeah
hindenburg blowing up totally gay
but it will be fun when the republicans
pick up on that yeah nice
mitt romney apparently people think the
president's totally gay
[Laughter]
it will work today snoop dogg
endorsed ron paul for president
snoop dogg endorsed ron paul president
snoop said he likes paul's positions on
everything from legalizing pot to
legalizing pot
[Applause]
it's interesting in the newspaper
studies show that republican candidates
the republican candidates are buying a
lot of ad time on the weather channel
they're buying like they're buying most
of their ad time on the weather channel
yeah in fact whenever the forecast calls
for rain they pay the weather men to say
thanks a lot obama
yeah and it works
[Music]
crazy story in iowa this weekend a woman
gave birth
to a 13-pound baby
apparently it's the heaviest baby born
in iowa since the last baby born in iowa
[Applause]
23 pounder
born fully clothed
came out actually drinking corn syrup
yeah
and holding a salted ham yeah
i've got the photos remember fran
drescher well in a recent interview fran
drescher claims that she was once
abducted by aliens
it was a mistake aliens made just once
take her back immediately
her voice just pleases me much
but we haven't done the probe
we will not be doing the probe
i want to stress before this next one
she's going to be okay
i love when i say that before a joke
she's gonna be okay
but a 17 year old girl is being treated
for malnutrition after eating nothing
but chicken mcnuggets for the past 15
years
doctors are describing her condition as
american
they say
they put her on an all quarter pounder
with cheese diet so
she should be fine yeah i wonder what
dipping sauce she used i'm curious about
that oh
i'm a honey mustard guy myself huh any
honey mustards here
[Laughter]
sorry uh
check this out nbc has decided not to
air an episode of fear factor we're
content where we're
that's all you needed to hear
[Applause]
i'm just happy it's not gonna air
he's a barbecue sauce guy
no nbc has decided not to air an episode
of fear factor where contestants had to
drink donkey semen
nbc made the decision after they were
sued for plagiarism by the cast of
jersey shore
[Applause]
thank you
i can't believe you can get an oscar for
a joke
i was i was afraid it was a chalice of
donkeys
[Applause]